hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over part 1 of the Kings gambit
opening and the Kings gambit is a very
aggressive opening and I like it for a
few reasons one of the main reasons I
like it is most players just are not too
familiar with how to defend it properly
your average player may not have even
seen the opening much less know how to
defend it and even your more experienced
players even at the club level a lot of
times they don't know how to defend the
various lines that you can throw at them
so we're going to kind of go over some
of the key concepts of the Kings gambit
so that if you do decide to play it you
will be ready so the King's game that
starts out pawn to e4 and black responds
pawn to e5 and white offers up a
sacrifice of pawns on f4 now this does
two things one it initiates an attack on
the King side right away we've already
started attacking the second thing it
tries to undermine black center control
for anyone that's played chess or
studied chess for any amount of time you
know that the center is a very crucial
part of the board and so right away why
it is basically saying I want to take
away your control in the center now
black has two options here he obviously
can decline and not take our free pawn
that we are trying to gambit but today
we're actually going to be looking at
the accepted line so when black does
take so we will go ahead black takes on
f4 and white really has two options here
the first one that we're going to
briefly touch on is I'll move the
Fischer used to play a lot and that is
Bishop to c4 now if you're very new to
the
but I'm actually going to recommend a
different move too just because I think
it's a little easier to play not that
this move is bad and will actually do
another tutorial on it at a later time
but after Bishop to c4 and Queen to h4
check King to f1 I feel like it's a
little tougher to play white in this
position your king is in a bad position
he can't castle your Brookes going to
have a hard time coming out you
definitely are going to gain some some
momentum as you eventually move your
knight to f3 chasing the Queen away you
will have some development pieces as he
retreats his Queen but starting out
actually think there's a little better
move that you can try out I think I
think you should have a lot of success
with it and that is just simply Knight
to f3 and the first thing it does
obviously you are developing one of your
minor pieces and the second thing it
does is stops Queen blacks Queen from
coming down and checking you so for the
time being your king is safe now
black obviously has a lot of different
options here and in today's tutorial we
are going to go over if they try to hold
on to the pond if someone's not too
familiar with the King's game at a lot
of times they will try to hold on to
material a lot of players if they get up
material they want to hold on to that
and so we are going to go over the move
pawn to g5 and you'll see this a lot by
black this pawn is now protecting his
pawn on f4 and we can't go ahead and
take it right now because his queen is
also defending this pawn on d5 what you
do see already though is black his
weakened his King side more and so we
are going to go after him immediately
and start attacking first thing we're
going to do it's and move pawn to h4 and
this immediately tries to take away this
Square from the defender he can always
take our pond and after we take his pawn
is hanging and eventually we can just
play our pawn to d4 and our bishop on c1
will be free to take his pawn them will
be back even in material so a lot of
times you'll see black just respond come
down and attack our knight and another
good thing about this pawn on h4 is it
sets up a defender for the knight when
we move it to Knight to g5 and you can
already see that we are in blacks base
and his King side is weakened so we are
going to start an attack now a lot of
times black in this position there's two
different moves we're going to go over
right now a lot of times black will try
to get the knight out of there and they
will try to initiate a move to make
white move so first we move you may see
is just simply pawn to h6 attacking the
knight here the knight obviously can't
go back to h3 he'll be take in can't go
to f3 he'll be taken that can't go to e4
because of his piece there can't go to e
6 or he'll be taken and his other move
is f7 so black right away is basically
saying move your knight we're actually
going to have a another sacrifice here
and we're going to attack the f7 square
and for many people that have studied
chest they know that the f7 Square is a
very big weakness for black and so we
were going to go ahead and take it and
then when black recaptures you already
see blacks entire defense around his
King is gone and his King is in a very
bad position now eventually we can bring
our Bishop out here to c4 in check get
our bishop involved we also want to get
our queen involved on g4 anytime black
tries to defend his pawn at the
beginning you always always want to get
your Queen to g4 the Queen on g4 is just
devastating for many reasons so if we
look at we need to decide which one
we're going to do first and if you look
at it if Bishop to c4 first black can
easily come down with his pawn
to d5 and block and at the same time his
Bishop on c8 is now defending the pawn
on g4 and obviously since we want to get
our Queen to g4 that's not going to be
our first move our first move we're not
going to put them in check yet we're
going to go ahead and take on g4 now the
Queen is very active he can do a lot of
things and so Black has to try to figure
out how to stop this attack we have many
different options that we have we can
always come in the future bring our
Bishop into the attack c4 once we bring
our Bishop into the attack as you can
see once we castle our rook is going to
be on the F file lined up with the King
here that's another key concept to
remember about the Kings gambit is
you're basically giving up your pawn on
the F file but once you castle your rook
now becomes very active on this F file
and you should use that a lot too to
attack along the F file especially if
you can get rid of this pawn here many
times you'll see them try to defend the
King just by bringing the knight out and
at the same time attacking the Queen but
here we can just go ahead and
tack the knight and take a pawn with the
night is now pinned and at any time now
we can we can still check the King we
can move this pawn attacking the knight
that's pinned he can no longer move if
black were to try to stop us from moving
our pawn again we can always come check
we can castle and have a rook Queen
battering ram going so there's a lot of
different possibilities that we can have
so definitely like this line it's a very
dynamic way to play it another thing
they could do coming back this situation
is just come up to f6 and try to attack
and here we're obviously not going to go
straight to f7 because there's not a
place there we're just not going to
worry about we're going to go ahead and
come Queen to g4 again you want to come
to Queen to g4 if you can and here even
if they take we don't care we're going
to go ahead and check them and then when
the Queen moves so we're going to go
ahead and take another piece and force
them to move again now here we are
threatening the same thing we can always
bring our bishop here if he doesn't make
a strong move we can always get our
other Knight involved again we can
always castle bring him into the attack
so a lot of different options that you
have black is going to be in a lot of
trouble you can always develop your
Bishop in your knight Castle queenside
and your King will be pretty safe now
keep in mind none of his minor pieces or
major pizzas have moved so although you
are down a material you definitely have
a lot of tempo and momentum and you
should have pretty good results so
everyone thanks for checking out the
video check out the website the chess
website comm and look back for more
videos